ahora vamos a hacer unos cuantos
ejercicios de la página de khan academy
para verificar que todo nos haya quedado
super claro aunque entendemos
perfectamente el concepto del número
opuesto entonces estamos aquí en la
sección de ejercicios de números
opuestos dos de khan academy y tenemos
aquí una recta numérica en la cual
algunos números les han puesto en letras
y nos preguntan qué podemos decir acerca
del punto b lo que hay acerca de este
punto que está una marca a la derecha
del cero y tenemos que elegir todas las
opciones correctas
así es que pues vamos a resolverlo lo
primero que nos tenemos que preguntar es
si d es igual a el que está por aquí una
rayita de la derecha del 0 y está a 3
rayitas a la derecha del 0 entonces
definitivamente no es igual a él aunque
entonces no vamos a seleccionar esta
opción bueno ahora vamos con algunas de
estas opciones
pero se me antoja más empezar por esta
opción a ver de es igual a menos be o en
otras palabras de es el opuesto dvd pues
ve esta una rayita a la izquierda del 0
entonces el opuesto bebé o menos b tiene
que estar una rayita a la derecha del 0
o sea justo aquí ok y de también está
una rayita a la derecha del 0 entonces
de si es igual a menos que de si es el
opuesto bebé bueno finalmente vamos con
esta opción de aquí de será el opuesto
de a
pues a está por acá está uno dos tres
rayitas a la izquierda del cero entonces
el opuesto de a tiene que estar tres
rayitas a la derecha del cero aunque
tiene que estar uno dos tres rayitas a
la derecha del cero o sea que lo opuesto
de a es el pero de se encuentra
únicamente una rayita a la derecha del
cero así es que de no es el opuesto de a
entonces que tampoco tenemos que
seleccionar esta opción a ver
comprobemos nuestra respuesta
excelente bueno ahora que podemos
decidir acerca de menos de que tenemos
que elegir todas las opciones correctas
- b es igual a de b está una rayita a la
izquierda de 0 por lo cual menos b tiene
que estar una rayita a la derecha de 0
justo aquí y de si está una rayita a la
derecha de 0 entonces menos b si es
igual a de la siguiente opción es menos
b es igual a bb a ver de esta una rayita
a la izquierda del cero y menos b está
una rayita a la derecha del 0 entonces
definitivamente no son iguales y bueno
de hecho para que estos dos fueran
iguales para que el opuesto de un número
sea igual al número ese número tiene que
ser cero cierto entonces no debemos de
seleccionar esta opción bueno vamos con
el siguiente - b es el opuesto bb
esta tenemos que saber inmediatamente
que es cierta porque justo estábamos
viendo hace unos cuantos vídeos que para
tomar el opuesto de un número sólo
tenemos que tomar menos ese número
comprobando respuesta
excelente a ver qué podemos decir acerca
del punto ce pues se es igual a 0 no así
es que bueno que nos aquí esta opción c
si es igual a cero está justo aquí y
bueno por acá 0 si es igual a menos 0
aunque hay porque 0 es 0 marcas a la
derecha de cero y menos cero es cero
marcas a la izquierda de cero y los dos
se quedan exactamente en cero entonces
cero si es igual a menos cero bueno si
es igual a menos y ahora se es igual a
menos menos pues claro que sí porque
esto sucede para cualquier número c
muy bien